find the domain of f of X is equal to
the principal square root of 2x minus 8
so the domain of a function is just the
set of all of the possible valid inputs
into the function or all of the possible
values for which the function is defined
and when we look at the how the function
is defined right over here as the square
root the principal square root of 2x
minus 8 it's only going to be defined
when it's taking the principal square
root of a non-negative number and so 2x
minus 8 2 X minus 8 it's only going to
be defined when 2x minus 8 is greater
than or equal to zero it can be zero
because it you just take the square root
of zero is zero it can be positive but
if this was negative then all of a
sudden this principal square root
function which we're assuming is just
the plain vanilla one for real numbers
it would not be defined so this function
definition is only defined when 2x minus
8 is greater than or equal to zero and
then we could say what if 2x minus 8 has
to be greater than or equal to zero we
can solve this inequality to see what
it's saying about what X has to be so if
we add 8 to both sides of this
inequality you get let me just add 8 to
both sides you get these 8 to cancel out
you get 2x is greater than or equal to 8
0 plus 8 is 8 and then you divide both
sides by 2 since 2 is a positive number
you don't have to swap the inequality so
you divide both sides by 2 and you get X
needs to be greater than or equal to 4
so the domain here is the set of all
real numbers where that are greater than
or equal to 4 X has to be greater than
equal to 4 or in other words saying this
function is defined when X is greater
than equal to 4 and we're done